what's the deal with airplane peanuts
from special holiday
episodes to all the comedy Staples these
are the best podcast moments from the
month of December starting off with Hoy
Mandel and Sam Talon on Matt and Shane
secret podcast you know they dedicated a
wing to me there a chicken
wing hold for the laugh I'm waiting
whatever it's not
coming whatever there you are you just
hit an hour yeah you just hit an hour I
love the signal there's a guy off
camera you can pull whatever out of here
no I know I gotta go because he's got
[__] to do he doesn't have he has to
need a big meatball sub yeah no he's got
[__] he doesn't have time he doesn't
have time this is crazy I have time for
you how we can hang out oh now who's got
[__] that was [__] time I got to
hang out with him I got to [__] hang
out with Sam I like a real good nipple
and a nipple could ruin a perfect tit
exactly and that's the that's the
problem for me with fake boobs is I know
they're beautiful and ladies fellas if
you want fake boobs you do it I support
you but you always have they always they
have to remove the nipple and then sew
it back on and that blow that that ruins
it for me which scar do you prefer do
you prefer the undercar or the nipple
Scar the underscar for me it's the
underscar because I don't want you to
disparage the nipple I don't want my
nipple messed up interesting the I want
I want I like an underscar so do they
isn't there a technique where they like
go through the armpit now like there's a
whole different just set of rules for
new titties but I think I'm a I'm a
nipple guy because I do like it's almost
like you know the the grass length from
from rough to Fairway to Green I like
that there's a little bit of a rais scar
around it so I know exactly when I'm on
the bullseye dude I was with a girl once
and she had like a botched like she was
beautiful and she had nice fake boobs
but when she took her shirt off she had
so many her her boobs look like Bane's
back in
Batman I was born lopsided she goes take
them take them take back the [__] take
back the titty it's
yours what's the craziest thing you've
done on a
bender jerk off a long time
whoa what a wild
night you normally hear these cocaine
people oh I did a line off a tit this
snorted out of a girl's [__] not you
when you say a long time how much how
long is that that's a great I I I
estimate like 2 hours 45 minutes wa 2
hours and 45 minutes oh my God you
[__] Schindler's fisted it that is
incredible did you not get bored 45
minutes in no no I had to come down oh
my God you know the release coming down
from you for two hours oh like usually
always yeah for 2 hours uh around there
yeah it's always around 2 hours it's sof
for about one of those hours so you
right right that makes sense and do you
get on the air mattress and you're just
sweaty on the air mattress and yeah
you're sticking to it like a Haan on his
way to
America jerking off like it isz just a
Cuban Refugee like a migrant and it's
three-year-old nephew peeking through
the door and it's deflating so it's like
I'm floating like a refugee right it's
amazing this is a beautiful country it
really is it is amazing this is where
someone barely barely surviving can find
a little bit of cocaine and jerk off for
2 hours and 45 minutes if I had to
estimate 2 hours and 45 minutes for your
exact words which makes it look like you
had a clock that you were timing
yourself with no no Oppenheimer was on
oh okay Oppenheimer is
on that makes makes complete
sense that makes complete sense and
meanwhile you're just dropping movie to
jerk off to on an air mattress in Waco
yeah staring at nuclear explosions y
working on your own Manhattan Project
over
there absolutely incredible that's wild
did you time it so that you came when
the bomb went off I was hoping yeah yeah
you dirty
bastard I love
history bro I can't wait to see what you
do when you find the Pearl Harbor movie
dude you're going to [__] lose your
[__] I have the greatest Keith Robinson
Story of all time there we go please
I've told this on many podcast I've
never told it in front of you I don't
think couple years
back uh my aunt passed away right we
were really close and she passed away I
was very sad so I was down in Jersey
with my family trying to help you know
with everything and it's sucked and
Keith for whatever reason was calling me
like every day cuz he wanted to talk to
me about something and I wasn't
answering and I also wasn't calling him
back cuz I was dealing with my dead aunt
and it was a horrible time sure horrible
that close with the aunt very close
second mother so got it we're in and it
was also the the like fifth person in
many deaths in my family in a short
period it was a very bad time so anyway
I'm
driving I'm driving my hand to God I'm
driving from the funeral mass to the
cemetery to bury her okay I'm in the
funeral procession you know and you
drive like 10 miles an hour things and
my phone rings and it's Keith again and
I'm like this what the [__] with this
[__] guy so finally I answer I go
yeah hello and he goes listen to me you
[__] [__] when I call you you
call me the [__] back you take my calls
you piece of [__] what the [__] you got
going on that you can't take my [__]
calls you got nothing happening right
and I go well Keith if you need to know
uh my aunt died so I've been dealing
with that for the last few days I'm
driving to bury her right now okay
that's why I called you back okay there
just a long pause he just
goes yeah an always bug
me ah you never met her that's go that's
why it's funny I mean just a piece of
[__] I'm I'm a good dude man yeah a good
guy you're doing a tank top every day D
yeah wife beater or like tank top wife
beater no matter what you doing a black
wife beater every day yeah you are a
dirt bag yeah yeah totally
totally yeah I'm I'm like a superhero I
wear my [__] outfit under my clothes at
all times what do you take my shirt off
and put a tank top on afterward I'm look
like an ass it Feats the whole purpose
of the tank top is that also
preventative maintenance so if you do
end in a frisky situation you're
completely covered let me tell you
something frisky what if we're in I just
watched Stallone daylight yesterday what
if we're underground and surrounded by
fire in a tunnel and it's hot and
everyone's taking their shirt off cuz
it's so hot well I got to be able to
take my shirt off too and not be fully
embarrassed I mean dude so tank top cuz
I still even feel I go I think we're
getting die here guys that guy's got a
lot of stretch marks I I think we're
going to die guys man are those tits are
[__] pecs guys I can't breathe wow
dude daily take top in case it pops off
anything pops off yeah literally
anything postapocalyptic [__] uh a [__]
sesh could be a loose stripper or
[__] terrorist could it could be a
time where I just have to do this
um what way Third
Street just got a little itch on my tum
tum there goes what up you guys thinking
for dinner huh Jesus oh man you're nuts
can tell you something [__] and
taking off my sweatshirt to start [__]
and the tank tops coming up with it is
the worst moment ever so you're tucked
into the pants Oh I yeah but I tued into
the underwear no but IED you haven't
pointed up in the ' 80s the 80s the man
he wouldn't be getting late if he was I
don't know what this guy this guy's all
over the road well here's why he look I
don't know you're if I'm a girl you look
clean thank you yeah that's what I'm
saying if I was a woman I'd be like no
this guy's fine yeah thank
you also I wouldn't be afraid of you
getting me pregnant I figured you know
like you decent genetics like no no no
no no I feel like they would be um
they're swimm relax but they're not
going the right direction right okay
yeah yeah they're going back in do you
think I'm infertile or just no no you
have a lot of sperm but they go back
into your penis okay and all you get is
the liquid part okay yeah but they're
back in I think they get nerved they get
out there and they're like oh no and
they go right back thank you they get a
little I think they get a little tepid I
I also think that your testicles are
cozy oh like warm balls warm warm balls
I love this whatever the opposite of
bullying is jebba let's go back I don't
know what their names are bigger what's
the bigger what's the bigger testicle
right or left I don't know are they
different sizes they sure are one hangs
lower for sure I just learned they moved
like recently they go wherever they want
recently you we never in cold weather
but I mean like you can hold them and
then they they they like they're kind of
like uh those Mexican jumping beans kind
sorry Carlos no but that's what they're
they're call I know thank you sorry
respect it's by the way somehow Mexican
jumping beans is sounds so racist not
what they're it just sounds like
something Trump said it does I was at
the airp they're Mexican jumping beans
right over the wall over the wall they
go bing bang
Bing it sounds like he said Mexican
jumping beans 2007 I just started comedy
in LA and we go watch there's a every of
the like the three major clubs had their
black night comedy stores was tripping
on Tuesday which wasn't the roughest
room but it's like it can be choppy
Sebastian goes on stage I'm watching
this white dude goes it's dead he lets
the silence sit for like 10 15 seconds
this white dude all black room and then
he just then one girl Woos and he just
goes no I like that confidence and then
the confidence he had I swear to you I
don't think to this day I've ever seen a
comic level a room like that I think
you're talking about Kramer at the laugh
at no dude it's not a racist show it's
not going to inspire me to do anything
bad it's comedy I say it to my crowd all
the time I was like just get friends
please I can start selling shows out if
you just have a friend right I listen
women travel in packs yeah women talk to
other women about this stff what do I
have to do do I have to watch The
Bachelor I to start Nick it's whole
thing it's not just ABS you know what it
is you have to relate it's not even ABS
no it's like you have to like be cute
watch selling Sunset those types of
shows that being in shape is never done
talk about selling s but I relate it to
Israel and Hamas
that's not that doesn't cuz I said the
hottest real estate show right now is
the Hamas War right it's even hotter
than selling sens that's a brilliant
take are women appreciating that I don't
think so speaking of big old butts
stabos halak halikas stavi baby has a
special and it's awesome I don't know if
you've seen it I watched it yesterday it
was awesome is the best he we love him I
I I posted about it uh yeah check it out
if you haven't stav's the best I started
to watch it last night and then I uh
indulged in um um some stuff that put me
to sleep what what do you mean I smoked
oh you smoked okay okay I thought you
meant like you watched somebody else's
special and that one put you to
sleep we okay let's think about this I
guess here's all you ready for a plot
yep you have a beautiful Angelic family
you and your you're married your husband
you know you guys have an adopted kid
running around whatever I am your maybe
I'm your cousin maybe I'm your brother
I'm freshly divorced my wife kicks me
out of the house house I'm maybe I'm old
school maybe I'm a little homophobic I
haven't really like figured it my [__]
out yet you what about the
movie what's up everybody Robert Kelly
yany swap Edition on the RS I'm Louis
Jay Gomez no don't do that no you are
not in [__] control of this you're
trying to be in control I'm trying to
get always been in control of yan we
started over cuz we were talking over
each other too much come on the wor
let's go we got to beat the part you're
the wor I'm literally the common
denominator you're the worst it's dance
Soder and Joe
list
JZ I'm no no take your ball on [__]
here ruin I'm just going to sit here
nice at a date go you [__] '90s
[__] what do you play third base with
the pad Bru over here hey Ken cetti why
don't you [__] relax
that was a good one to D go to it was
great brought it back in we're going you
know what it tickles your your
heart got you we're live welcome to the
show folks I'm your host Jo and swap I
brought the swap in come swap you didn't
bring the Swap and it is I The Voice
King who brought in the swap you did me
Lord The Voice
get that shirt The Voice King dude I'm
the voice Queen yeah are you forced to
kind of always give more positive spins
on what you're hearing or seeing I just
share what I receive people always ask
me has the animal ever said that they
hate their life they hate their their
family and the answer is no because
people who are paying me to do this
probably care about their animals right
but some of these animals probably were
rescues or adopted from a shelter which
is a great thing but maybe their
previous owner sexually molested them
has an animal ever told you that they
were sexually molested no I can
confidently say no what about kidnapped
has an animal ever said hey I've been
taken this isn't my rightful owner nope
but I had an animal say they voluntarily
just left it was a pig he left where he
was cuz he hated it and they didn't have
enough time for him you know a lot of
times when someone commits a horrific
crime they like to go back and they
stand and they like to you know in
movies this I'm basing this on movies uh
they they go back to the police line and
they're just kind of watching like oh
wonder wonder who did this so I'm
thinking maybe there's ay guy out there
that sexually molested his dog and then
wants to get a reading just to see if
his dog's going to talk I'm very
thankful that person has never cross my
path that would infuriate me if I was
ratted out by my daugh it's a big nose
it is what's it
from we don't know well you don't know
what your nationality is you never did
like a I did the 23 me you did what were
you part
bird sorry sorry that was too much that
was he it would have been good if he
didn't laugh like that I mean that was
too much that was fine no what were I'm
G
say so what was it what was it
like don't do that that's don't do that
that's scary that's my native tongue
what did you say my native tongue you're
good at callbacks there's this place in
Vegas called dicks Last Resort do you
know what that is Dicks it's it's a
restaurant where they insult you so the
whole thing is like you sit and they're
mean and they throw stuff I didn't know
that yeah I didn't know nobody told me
oh you I was unaware oh you w so I go
with Jordan yeah and our friends Taylor
and Brit we go in and this caty [__]
dude is like what do you want and I'm
like interesting approach and Jordan
goes we'd like a table for four and he
goes well you're out of luck we're all
out of food you can sit at the bar if
you want and I go excuse me and she
grabs my hand and I'm like I got this
and and he looks at me and goes what are
you the tattooed man or something and I
go oh did you run out of food cuz you
ate it all you fat [__] [__] you and
dude he fat yes oh yeah he dropped
character and goes I was just doing my
job and I'm like what are you mean and
they're like Ian Ian they're supposed to
be mean they're supposed to be mean and
he goes and I got to be honest I've been
feeling really low about my weight
recently and I was like I'm so sorry I'm
so sorry well you know you are but I'm
so sorry and I gave him and I was like
can I hug you and I hugged him and gave
him $20 and we left
$20 I'm not rich all right I was try to
like lose that was a $1,000 slam dude
that was $1,000 20 wow yeah how' you not
know like no one told you no oh wow I'm
thinking Dick's Last Resort yeah that's
me at the end of the night like I didn't
get [__] dick let's go wow and Jordan
was with you oh yeah heo going on he
what we're going to be talking you're
just going to slowly have like a negl on
I'm I don't know why I'm stretched like
this though but I'm hot don't fart I
don't don't fart don't
fart if you fart we do we were doing Sam
Mill and Mark Norman's podcast and Ian's
wearing a [__] what's his name Austin
pow outfit and all of a sudden Mark like
the king farter was like oh oh and Sam's
like oh and and heend like I'm sorry and
I look the producers are across the room
be
like dude I thought it was going to be
quick a all that old [__] falling on your
butthole it is so funny that
conversation you have with your [__]
before you fart you're just like please
don't
stay please don't stay L I know you burn
me in the past but I'm trust you one
more time as yeah dude give me one more
do the thing you did one time
do dude I know you told me you can
change that thing you did one time when
we were outside I'm going to let you out
remember
Church you better come right back in
when you're done it's like a dog go do
your thing and get right back in here I
swear you want to do leashless oh I see
you've done it again we're going do a
leashless walk today you're not going to
stink up the place all right second
somebody like you're like betrayal
betrayal you st Yonder oh dos have been
betrayed bring it in bring it in bring
it in you look like you drive a
Harley is that a question no I'm just
I'm baiting for I'm just going to say
things about you now you look like the
foremost realator in Dallas Fort wor
Texas your face should be on Bunch B bu
B like that's [__] you look like you
drive home you do don't you I don't do I
do you have a Harley do you have a
motorcycle no I'm [__] horrified to
be on like my lack of balance are you
[__] kidding me didn't sleep much
last night and the elves
have we had to let one go we didn't kill
him or drop him off a mountain but I
didn't think that's what you meant
great we had to fire him for being
racist and for being a little touchy
feely what kind of racist stuff did he
say exactly oh I don't want to say it NW
but you said the nword a lot and I don't
like that but correct me if I'm wrong
was this the
elf I'm not going to correct
you so he's allowed to
say he's allowed to say it but not in
front of uh you
know not in
front
oh sound it out with
me look I will only say it if
I
I tomato tomato Ray Romano she got her
this is kicking in and it is pretty
strong yeah do you feel it I think it's
tobacco I think it is too I think it's
tobacco I don't think these are [__]
and is Russian tobacco not regulated but
by the way I have to [__] right now
because nicotine this strong makes me
[__] I can feel my ass being like what
are we doing here find a hole man is
[__] whoa I'm high I got a crazy Buzz
God these ruskies are out of their minds
it's like pouring into my mouth have you
seen what those crazy [__] do
for holy cow for
I'm really high that's VI painted that I
know uh that's not bad but it says on it
now says that's not the finished product
on either it says enough
already uh so on the left side it says
e what are you talking about it's not on
there yet smiley face no no no I know
I'm saying so this is a work in progress
that we were shooting in my apartment
and I held that up cuz pimp said hold up
this thing you're painting oh got you
it's it now the finished version of it
says enough already it says enough down
the left and already on the right but
the enough is spelled it's it's like a
contracted version of each word so
already is spelled a LR d
y you understand yeah yeah yeah yeah are
you trying to make it better I don't
what are you saying what do you mean
what am I saying I'm saying the finished
painting says enough already on it that
that's not the finished pain is that
what is the point are we supposed to go
oh no I'm just saying that's not the
finished pain oh this is why I don't get
into the painting yeah I don't want this
you ask me why I wrote those words on it
no I just why did you even say anything
I guess is it doesn't Elevate the
painting that much no it
does if you saw it it does all right I'm
saying I guess I'm saying is I'm saying
that's not
finish that's all I don't know I'm proud
of you Joe thanks keep at it man i i p
did a lot of dark uh stuff last year
yeah yes and now you're all happy no the
that's the point of the wording the MTH
it's saying like enough of this [__]
aren't you tired of smiling for no
reason it's all terrible 1 million per.
yeah there you go you get it you get it
see I'll show you that God I'm about to
be homeless I'll show you
that uh go ahead what were you going to
I thought you were going to say
something no I just looked like I always
know I want to congratulate you for what
wearing the worst pants I've ever seen
comedy podcasting stats from November
stav Rose made the most guest
appearances last month going on 10 total
podcasts including The Joe Rogan
Experience kill Tony tigerbelly bad
friends we might be drunk two bears one
cave are you garbage fear and the Rich
Eisen show and H3 after dark the top
three most viewed episodes from last
month starts off with Kat Von D and Theo
Von on this past weekend with 1.6
million views in second place we have
Tim Dylan on kill Tony which currently
stands at 1.5 million views which is
tied with stavos on kill Tony also at
1.5 million views if you enjoyed this
monthly recap video and want to stay in
the comedy Loop be sure to subscribe to
joke world right now and if you really
want to get involved check the link
below to go vote in the first annual
joke World Awards a fan driven Comedy
Award Show voted on by the subscribers
of this channel categories include
comedian of the Year special of the Year
podcast and podcast guest of the year
and many more also just a quick shout
out to every one who purchased some joke
World merch over the past few weeks
thanks to you guys we were able to
donate 2,100 meals to a local food bank
and although the food drive portion of
our merch sales is now over you can
still purchase joke World merch if
interested using the link in the
description below happy New Year and
thank you for
watching joke
world
world and the world is
wld that's a great uh YouTube channel
joke world check it out